une vieille plaque michelin en céramique
des années 30
dès l'entrée de la cité le ton est donné
à luynes on aime le patrimoine
on respecte les vieilles pierres les
boulangers sont tombés amoureux de leur
village il ya sept ans on un joli
village un coeur de village voilà c'est
plutôt agréable à vivre
on est à la campagne et projet d'avis
tout près de la halle du 15e où se tient
le marché hebdomadaire la façade de la
maison de nicole raconte son passé
commercial fruits poêle à bois
cette normande a travaillé 35 ans au
château ducal situé juste au dessus de
château ce jeu vous pouvez apercevoir si
vous avez pas le fier vous allez voir
les tours vous attendez voir les
anciennes douves qui sont sèches mais
qui sont aménagé en jardin en
et on met des arbustes pour obtenir le
label petite cité de caractère il faut
respecter plusieurs critères une belle
densité de bâtiment historique préservé
moins de 6000 habitants et un projet de
développement touristique
un petit label de plus si ça peut faire
venir des touristes pour le commerce et
et l'activité locale
c'est vraiment très bien entre la grange
en bas qui a été rénové les kits les
bâtisses sont magnifiques la petite
place avec le marché le samedi matin un
très beau château c'est ces magnifiques
quoi l'ancienne grange où lennon de
l'hôpital étant des le linge reflète
bien l'esprit de la ville entre
l'histoire de france la loire la vie
d'aujourd'hui et l'avenir on se trouve
en face de l'ancienne lingerie de
l'hôpital du calme cet ancien hôpital a
été rénové et donc aujourd'hui vous vous
y voyez une grange en fait derrière ces
murs il ya un cinéma dernier cri avec
toutes les installations comme il faut
et puis également on y adjoint une salle
d'exposition pour le volet justement
plus contemporain luynes est l'une des
trois premières petites cités de
caractère
retenu en val de loire une dizaine
d'autres sont déjà en lice pour obtenir
le label